[Music]
nice to have you here it's it's nice to
be here then someone pointed it out to
me today cuz I didn't realize we've been
doing this show a long time someone said
to me today it's been 13 years since I
last interviewed you 14 actually 14 yeah
seems like 13 to me three showed three
shows in two networks ago okay and I'm
curious was there a reason why yeah from
my end there was not I wasn't I I felt
like I've always liked you I think
you're a terrific guy and a great actor
and I thought someone said it's been
that long since you've been on the show
nights wanting what was the issue with
the issue yeah here's the thing I I've
got a pretty good job of I feel like of
not being a douchebag most of my career
right but into every teen idols life a
little douchebaggery must fall and for
whatever reason my douchiness peaked on
your show really only on the air 14
years ago 14 years ago let's talk about
what's going on you were very young and
riding very hard is 21 years old varsity
blues was opening yeah I was hosting
Saturday Night Live that week yeah and
our on Dawson's Creek is on to us
everything's hitting for you and I
thought for whatever reason that I was
cool enough to pull off tinted glasses
tinted glasses I'm it's funny because
you bring us up and I don't remember it
but you wore tinted glasses yeah and I'm
not bono and you're not bono yeah I was
curious I heard about this and we went
and we found a picture of you on my show
back
[Applause]
the head you look like a German lesbian
I know
and II never the hairdo was the claw
yeah exactly I like the claw that's a
very good hair too it's about to take
something up in an amusement park that's
about to put those glasses off my head
say don't be a douche bag yeah so you
feel like oh yeah that you were
self-conscious about the appearance yes
I was all right and then yeah yeah I
told a couple long boring stories that
had no it's funny I just so you know I
have no memory of any of that we're
thrilled that you're here now and that
the glasses are gone
[Laughter]